david who could actually defeat trump in
the 2024 republican primary
you know i don't know how to answer this
question unconditionally because
it all depends on whether republicans
still like and support trump in 2024
we we talked with bill share earlier
this week
and he explained something that is
intuitive to many of us which is until
we know what happens in 2022
and we see whether trump is in or out of
favor
with republican voters and the
republican elected officials
between 2022 and 2024 how can we say
what the outcome would be of a 2024
primary with trump as
a candidate if donald trump still has
the majority of the republican
electorate behind him as he does today
nobody can beat him quite simply nobody
would be able to beat donald trump
if come 2024 the numbers are as they are
today
which is nearly two-thirds of republican
voters say if trump started his own
party
i would go with him and abandon the
republican party something like 85
percent of republican voters
want donald trump involved in politics
to some degree if donald trump
successfully plays kingmaker in 2022
because people donate to his save
america pack
and then he successfully primaries some
so-called rhinos that he doesn't like
republicans in name only basically
republicans that don't like trump like
mitt romney
if trump gets his you know the kawthorne
bobert
marjorie taylor green types reelected
and runs in 2024 nobody's going to be
able to defeat trump
in the republican primary the general
election is another question
on the other hand if the republican
party
abandons donald trump anybody
could defeat donald trump if the donald
trump that runs in 2024
is sort of down and out all of his
friends
have lost in 2022 the republican party
has moved away from him
and it's become very clear that joe
biden's
pandemic response was the right response
and just
humiliates the failed response from
donald trump in 2020
um then trump really has no shot and a
lot of this has to do
with the midterms we don't know who will
be
re re-uh revived through the midterms if
people like
kawthorne beaubert and greene are
re-elected in the midterms then donald
trump could be sailing on the wings of
them and even more trumpian candidates
to 2024
on the other hand it could go very
differently if the midterms don't go
well for republicans bill share said
earlier this week that he has this
hypothesis
that one party has the
has to lose the white house three times
in a row before you see real
introspection
and change if he's even partially right
trump merely losing in 2020 is not going
to be enough
what we see over the last several weeks
is that while
trump's polling is still strong within
republicans his political stature
is diminished search interest in trump
is being diminished his public
statements seem particularly pathetic
like when he put out that statement
saying
please remember when you get the vaccine
that it's thanks to me
it was increasingly pathetic so we'll
have to see what happens in 2022
it's not clear to me that democrats get
killed in the midterms
traditionally the expectation is when a
party
takes the white house from another party
in one year
in the immediate midterms two years
later they get crushed
doesn't always happen but but it often
does i don't know that it's going to be
uh the way it goes in 2022 i think it's
just early but i think there's a lot of
reasons that democrats could actually do
okay if there is not and a lot of this
has to do with covet and the economy
barring some like terrible covid variant
mutation
that completely outruns the vaccines we
have a vaccination program right now
that's going
well and we are likely to have uh
modified boosters
from pfizer and moderna maybe as soon as
the fall may be january which will deal
with
the the newer variants if we deal with
the pandemic
vaccination continues going well and it
will be attributed
at least partially to joe biden taking
over he got the stimulus bill done
if the economy does well and the economy
is expected new goldman sa and listen
goldman sachs love them or hate him
their timeline
last april about the pandemic was
exactly right they predicted late
november early december healthcare
workers will start being vaccinated
exactly the way it went they said here's
when the final
you know the big peak is going to be th
goldman sachs just put out an
um a prediction an analysis a forecast
that 2021 is going to be very good
economically for the country
if all of that happens it's not clear to
me that democrats go down in november of
2022. now
it's still a ways away we're still you
know 21 months or something from that
period and a lot can happen between now
and then but if biden essentially is
seen as the guy
who reopened the country did vaccination
and beat the virus i think it's tough to
say
republicans do super well in 2022
and that probably doesn't bode
particularly well for donald trump in
2024. all speculative
all early we'll wait and see you may not
have known this but when you see me
sitting here on the show i am often
wearing shirts by a company called teddy
stratford i asked them to be a sponsor
because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100 percent
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout